هذه اكبر نقطه تجمع للسفريات البريه هذا
هو الميناء البري للعاصمه الخرطوم مقتد
بالمغادرين لاصوات الرصاص والمدافع بعيدا
عن الحرب ولكل منهم قصه عاشها على ما يبدو
مع الحرب الذي اندلعت بين الجيش والقوات
الدعم السريع حرب روعه الابرياء الكبار
والصغار دوله التمييز صفحه كبيره من
الاستنكار لمسناه هنا في اوساط المغادرين
للعاصمه الخرطوم للحرب هم الان يحاولون
الاستفاده من الهدنه المعلنه لمغادره ارض
المعارك والمواجهات الى اهله وذويهم وعلى
الرغم ان ان الخروج من العاصمه محصور في
هذا المكان بالتوجه لوسط السودان جنوبا
بسبب اغلاق الجسود الا ان الذهاب من
المناطق الحرب الى اي مكان اخر امنه يشكل
منازل لهؤلاء يغيهم تجدد القتال الكل هنا
يقدم المنشدات للطرفين يوقفوا الحرب من
اجل الانسان من اجل السودان من اجل
السودان ويتمنون
ان تكون الهدنه هذه
وهدنه اليوم الثاني او يوم العيد سببا
وانطلاق لوقف دائم للحب وكذلك التعامل مع
هذه القضيه عن طريق الحوار هذا هو لسان
هذا الوضع هنا في الميناء البري للذين
يريدون مغادره العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
الطاهره الماضي الجزيره الخ